[Music]
what
drives blue yonder's commitment
consistent commitment to supporting the
open source ecosystem and to supporting
specifically pi data and num focus
so i think it's um it's the people at
blue yonder who
who drive this first and foremost um
the you know the engineers that we have
then they're passionate about the craft
they are passionate about the tools that
they use
and they they also like to share you
know many of us have a
background from university um we have
both
collaboration and and competition and
it's similar in the open source uh
community you know everybody's helping
out each other but still there's
there's some projects doing the same
things so it's friendly competition and
when you go to conference
uh in the open source community it's
very similar than you know to
to going to um to a scientific
conference
which blue yonder supported open source
project are you most proud of
which project do you think will have the
most impact on the industry
i would say carter take is like the most
the most interesting one because it
tries to solve
the problem how can i maintain large
tabular data
with very reasonable costs in a cloud
infrastructure
while still being able to you know to
manage consistency
um of of your data set so it
provides you with with easy access on
multiple
cloud stores i think that's that's
really cool um and
to see how it will interact with the
other tools in the in the environment
um and uh so that's that's one
um the other one is turbo dpc which is
um an odbc bridge for for python so you
can
basically use it with any database that
provides an odbc
driver and odbc is not like like the
the selling point but it's attempting to
use
binary data in the inside and trying to
expose the binary data
to python users as numpy arrays and
and pi arrow tables
[Music]
you